Pointing your hands in front and bowing.
So putting your hands on top of your head, leaning the body to the right.
To the left.
up hands at the back leaning backwards and straightening up bending down on the knees and stretching the toes rising and
Holding the knees and turning them round, first to the right and then to the left.
Hands on the hip and swinging the hips round to the right three times and three times to the left.
stretching up into the air and bringing the arms down behind you lifting up behind you and stretching the arms in front of you bending the fingers
and then bending each finger one after the other shaking the hands and standing on one leg begin to turn one of the
in a circle three times and then the other way pointing outwards stretching the foot forward standing on the other leg three times turning and the other way
And stretching forward.
Legs apart.
And stretching the shoulders.
Just lifting them up.
And turning them in as great a circle as you can.
And the other way.
And giving them a shake.
look behind you to the right and then to the left to the right and to the left to the right and to the left bending the head backwards
Backwards and forwards.
Bringing the hands down
twisting the arms round
And coming to a stop.
So from now on you're breathing in through the nose and out through the mouth.
So just lowering the body downwards.
And lifting it up.
Straight up into the sky.
and with the out-breath drawing your arms down towards the front
and back down to the afterwards.
with the out breath into the standing pose.
you.
bending down and lifting up with the in-breath.
Breathing out, stretching up.
Breathing in and bringing the arms down and out and then turning the hands.